finally I can sit here and say that I'm
reviewing God of War Ragnarok for the
PlayStation 5 developed by Saint Monica
and published by PlayStation let's get
on with the review what's going on you
guys Lord ad here coming at you with
another review you guys obviously know
what I'm about to review I'm about to
review God of War Ragnarok you guys know
that you know it's been a very
anticipated game for a lot of variety of
reasons I would say that the success of
the 2018 one which I did review on my
channel so you can go look at that if
you guys want to so there's a lot going
on this game I came into this with
pretty above expectations I'll actually
say that myself I really expected this
game to really hit out of the park the
question is did it out of the park I'm
gonna be reviewing this off of gameplay
story performance and obviously gameplay
again because you guys know how I love
gameplay so let's let's talk about the
story of God of War pretty much it's a
continuation of 2008 18 I would say this
is mainly focusing on atreus this time
and not much of Kratos which that was a
little bit of the focus in the 2018
version I actually don't mind this for
the most part there are a couple
nitpicks that I do have that I'll save
for a little bit later on in the video
but they do a good job explaining atreus
they do a really good job with his
character development I felt like
character development in this game was
very well done especially Kratos there's
a lot of aspects that people don't like
when it comes to Kratos in the 2018
where they feel like the older kratoses
would never turn into the current Kratos
and I'm not one of those people I feel
like if you want to do something
different with God of War you're gonna
have to change drastic characteristics
of Kratos and to me a battle veteran
that's went through Wars multiple times
went through his own personal Hells
multiple times and has died multiple
times in the original games of God of
War would make sense that once he found
something that he wants he's gonna grab
onto it and hold on to it and that's
what happened when he met atres his
mother and that's what happened when he
eventually had a trellis itself and
that's why I feel like it makes sense
that a little bit of that hearted shell
that he has would slowly start to come
down because he spent all of those years
in the original God of Wars avenging his
family's death so to me when he was able
to establish some form of that feeling
of that world back into him he would do
the exact thing thing he did back then
which was try to remain it because he
knows what happens if he goes too much
on this adventure when it comes to
Vengeance and he doesn't want that for
his son he's seen multiple times over
and over again how bad things can get
and he knows for a fact that look I'm in
this foreign land I've been here for a
while I'm trying to raise my kid and I'm
trying to atone to some form of the past
me of the past Kratos and when he met
Faye seems like she was able to break
down some of those walls those internal
struggles that he had and don't get it
twisted that old Kratos is still there
there are a couple times in the game
where you see it come back out but
Kratos has done everything in his power
to make sure he does not pass that hate
that Vengeance soul of his to his son
and I think that is the character
development in itself I can actually say
one of the biggest things I really
enjoyed about God over Ragnarok was the
acknowledgment of the original trilogy
now I have my own knacks that I felt
like they should be a little bit more
story opportunities going to happen
between the original games and these new
reboots but I'm not going to sit here
and tell you that I really enjoyed going
around seeing the banter between the
story members and exactly some of the
stuff that Kratos did because when you
know mimir and all them are talking
about you know the events of God of War
2. it's nice to see that that is a rumor
back then like there are some things
that they talk about that mamir himself
elf is like Kratos is this true because
this seems far-fetched and Kratos is
like yeah I did that I shouldn't have
did that but I totally did that and the
banter between these characters is
something I don't normally see in these
type of games I really enjoy that they
acknowledge the original games they were
pretty much Easter eggs where when
you're sitting there going through that
and you hear these conversations you
just you can't help to have a smile like
I remember playing that man and you know
that is a really good attention to
detail that I feel like a lot of you are
going to appreciate now let's talk a
little bit about the performance and
Graphics the performance of this I
played on the PlayStation 5 it was
phenomenal for the most part no real big
issues I didn't have no dropouts no
frame rate drops nothing like that the
game to my knowledge I don't think
crashed one time now obviously there are
occasions where these PlayStation games
and Xbox games and PC games they crash
it doesn't really matter what type of
patches out there what type of final
build sometimes the system itself just
you know let's go back to the main menu
but I wanted to say the PlayStation five
ran this very well it didn't really run
too hot and I did play digitally I don't
know what the PlayStation 4 edition of
this is I did play on the performance
mode I don't really care about that
graphic stuff or you know the Fidelity
of the screen I want the frame rates to
go more because this is like more of an
action-packed game but I can say on the
PlayStation 5 in performance mode you
should have no issues in terms of the
artwork you know how the graphics itself
is I will say that there is clearly an
upgrade from the 2018 version but I see
a lot of people acting like it's like
huge grips and I don't I don't
necessarily disagree with that but I
don't agree with that on its own I feel
like there's certain aspects of this
game that looks way better than 2018 for
instance I felt like some of the
animations looked a lot better felt like
some of the effects like fire water that
look better especially the frost on the
blade look pretty clean especially on
the PlayStation 5. I just feel like the
overall art style and the graphics
itself didn't look drastically better
clearly the majority of the map is
frozen over in God of War Ragnarok and
when it comes to midgar that is and the
original one it definitely wasn't frozen
over there is lore behind the reason
that all of midgars Frozen I thought
that was really interesting I hope you
guys enjoy that but for the most part
the game looks phenomenal runs great I
don't think you guys can have too many
issues with that I think I'm gonna put
this in there because it is part of the
graphics ah come on Sony PlayStation
Saint Monica like where's the gore in
this game you know some of the
animations are pretty good and I will
say it's better than the 2018
counterpart when it comes to gore but I
want that old God of War 3 back when you
rip people's heads off and you rip
people's limbs off and hit them with it
with the limb I feel like that's absent
in this now I know that we live in a
different world than we live back in
maybe that's too violent for today's
society but I do feel like if you want
God of War to come back to it's true
that Gore gotta be there and you guys
know everyone that played the old God
Awards you guys know what I'm talking
about you know there's a lot of sexual
stuff that's not in this game that was
in the previous ones and I'm not saying
that's necessary it's probably not
necessary but all that stuff together in
a pot made it feel more adult-like now
I'm not saying this game don't feel like
adult like there's still a lot of Gore
in this game but I guess my stance in
general would be look with the fighting
going on when it comes to gore you know
it's a fraction a shadow a shell of its
former self when it comes to that a lot
of you know the sexual activity has been
brought down to a minimum there's not
really any of that and it's like I said
it's not necessarily need to be there
but all that together made it feel more
of a mature game it's still a mature
game there's still a lot going on but I
feel like you know if you do another one
if you're able to bring some of that
back especially the goal or man I I
think everyone here that's played the
original God of Wars knows that that
Gore is one of the key components to a
god of war game so if we make more just
try to implement a little bit more of
that into it let's let's get into
gameplay because you guys know how I
feel about gameplay I enjoy gameplay and
I'm honestly say that the combat system
on here is pretty much almost identical
to the 2018 combat there are times where
the camera is annoying especially when
they're wanting to do a lot of traversal
there is a lot more of that you know you
feel like you have multiple areas to
fight in especially for the harder
difficulties I beat the difficulty
before the harder the hardest difficulty
I don't know exactly what the name of
that was but I did enjoy the fact that
if things were going wrong I had the
ability to climb or go down levels to be
able to restructure myself to be able to
see exactly who I'm fighting sometimes
they would outnumber me and I like the
fact that they've gave you diverse in
gameplay in anything you really want to
do they put elements on just about any
weapon you could think of the blades
have fire this ax has ice I do enjoy
this I enjoy the way the combat system
worked in this game especially with the
RPG system it just made it feel a lot
more like an RPG on top of having a
phenomenal story there are certain parts
of God of War that kind of like annoyed
me a little bit and I wouldn't
necessarily want to take points about it
but I do want to let you guys know there
are nitpicks that I got on it and there
is a certain part in the game where you
start you know traveling around with
actual Gods I'm sure some of you've seen
them in the trailer and you see them
vividly and just clearly jumping up
giant mountains they don't really take
any kind of chains or anything like that
and you don't see Kratos doing this and
I know they do it because they want to
you know they they gotta they gotta
ground him a little bit in order to make
gameplay that makes sense because if
Kratos was able to do these things that
he does in the cutscenes or you know the
animations and obviously the gameplay
itself would be hard but it kind of like
takes you a little bit out of the
immersion when you are stronger than
most of these people and they're doing
more than you are and I think that's the
biggest thing that I got had an issue
with the immersion now like I said I
know all that's done for gameplay issues
and I don't want any of you to defer not
playing this game because of that that's
going to have to be happen that's one of
of the reasons I feel like Superman
hasn't really had too many iterations of
that character in games because that
type of gameplay is hard to make and I
feel like the same thing goes here sure
you're a God but what are you really
supposed to do if you could kill
everyone on one hit you got to ground
that character down to a certain degree
but I feel like you know especially the
traversal stuff let me jump over
mountains or or something man let me
feel like a God sometimes because
sometimes you feel like an actual mortal
not a god like the god of war and
obviously he threw that name back a long
time ago but it's just like you still
have these god-like Powers you're a
demigod you should be able to have more
traversion when it comes to jumping over
little Cliffs and stuff I I know that's
a little small and I know I shouldn't be
annoyed by that but I don't know why it
just frustrated me the more and more I
saw these people doing these traversals
and I'm sitting there have to rely on
phrasing stuff I know it's for puzzles
and you know considering the puzzles
were pretty much the exact same thing
it's like pushed us here or freeze this
here or catch this on fire you know I
was tired of the puzzles like 20 30
minutes into the game
um I don't know why they fixed some of
these poses these are the exact
mechanics that was used in 2018 and it's
kind of frustrating that they're still
in this game but let's talk about boss
battles in general you know first off
let's get hit the elephant in the room
the biggest issue and the biggest
critique I personally had for God of War
2018 was the implementation of how many
trolls was put in that game that used to
be that you know you would see a certain
boss re-washed but that particular game
they reused that troll 20 30 times it
felt like it was like that trolls at the
end of every dungeon that trolls at the
end of every story element that wasn't
the main element I'm gonna honestly say
that they took that criticism very well
sure there was opportunities where I
felt like they could have been a little
bit more creative than just you know
taking a skeleton and giving them fire
powers and naming him some weird thing
and saying that's a boss now they could
have did more on that but as far as like
the different variety of enemies the
different variety of bosses I will say
that they improved on that now as far as
the big boss battles you know the
fighting the gods of the Nords or
anything related to have any form of
power something that you would get that
Zeus feeling from in the original God of
Wars that Poseidon feeling from I'll
actually say that there are good
capabilities and fights in this game and
you will get that Sensation that serious
stuff is going down but I I can't
honestly say that I was impressed by it
now I felt like they did better than
2018 for the most part the only real big
battles is like the dragon you fought
the stranger a couple times and that was
pretty much it this game it is a long
game it is about 30 hours and in the 30
hours there's probably a good six maybe
seven fights and I know there's some
stuff in the side missions that I
haven't got to yet and I got to a lot of
them but as far as like the main bosses
there are some that are hit there are
some that's a miss but I feel like they
did enough here to satisfy me now if
they make another one I want them to
focus more on the boss battles because I
think what makes God of War God of War
is that Gore is that M rated Gore that
that that destroy all things Gore that
rip people to shreds Gore that boss
battle where you know you come up to
Hercules and you take his own weapons
and Bash his skull in that is what makes
God of War to me and I feel like this is
God of War but it's downplayed a lot
significantly and maybe it's a lot to do
with you know budgeting I know that some
of these big AAA battles in the type of
style that God of War is currently going
into so maybe that takes a little bit of
time but they did a decent job it's like
I said I wouldn't say it's phenomenal or
anything like that when it comes to the
story in turns there were a couple
bosses towards the end of the game that
I was a little disappointed with that I
felt like they built up anticipation to
fight them and it just wasn't caught up
what it was to be you know I think that
this is a good direction for God of War
I don't know where they're gonna go next
with this but I'm kind of curious to see
exactly what the feedback they took from
this game when they're making the next
one because like I said this is a good
game guys you know they took a lot of
the feedback that the community gave
them and there was a lot of feedback you
know there was a huge thing on the ball
since people weren't feeling that the
stranger and the dragon was like one of
the key boss fights in the original God
of War that gave us a lot more of that
like I said I would appreciate more like
phase boss fights where you change
location there was a particular one
where you fought in pretty much their
version of hell that was a really nice
boss fight I really enjoyed that I would
like I just want more of that that's all
I just want more fights and maybe it's
because they don't have access to the
amount of gods that Greek mythology had
I don't know much about North mythology
if they have the amount of gods that
Greek mythology has but they had a lot
to work with in Greek mythology when it
comes to the original God of Wars and
maybe it's because their rash these with
just two games because if you guys think
about it in the original God of Wars
they had a lot of build up time when you
got to Zeus you really wanted to kill
Zeus when you got to anyone for that
matter you saw Hercules people know who
Hercules is they knew who they were
fighting there was a lot of things they
could work with those original games
because they built up to them from their
first God of War to the second God of
War to the third God of War that's why
because of the build up from the first
two God Awards they were able to jump
straight into the third God of War just
killing Poseidon the way they did I
think that might be the biggest issue
when it comes to the story of these
newer games now the story was fantastic
I do have nitpicks on it like I said
there were things towards the end of the
game that I was not feeling too much but
as far as the overall game the game is
is is amazing it really is I I recommend
all you guys buying it's worth seventy
dollars don't wait for this game if you
have a PlayStation 4 or 5 I would
probably wait for a five uh that's
probably just me I don't know how this
game would run on the PS4 it probably
runs the loading screens I couldn't even
imagine imagine but if you have a
PlayStation 5 go buy this don't wait to
go buy this you know go on your store
right now you know go ahead I'll give
you guys a couple seconds and buy this
game because stuff like this needs to be
supported so it shows we want more stuff
like this God of War Ragnarok is more
2018 and there's no hiding that a lot of
people like to call it like DLC there's
nothing wrong with being an over
glorified DLC if it's what you wanted
originally 2018 was one of the best
games that came out last generation and
to be honest with you God of War
Ragnarok is probably one of the best
games that's going to come out this
generation because they stuck to what
did very well they improved it on fan
feedback and they did more and
capitalize on everything else and that's
why I think this game is great on story
for the most part amazing on gameplay
and you know the it looks good it looks
really good it's a very eye candy
looking game and I think you guys will
enjoy this but that's it for the review
man uh did this get the iron seal of
approval from Ireland's podcast and I
will actually say it definitely got that
sill got the silver approval from us I
really enjoyed this and I hope that we
see more in the future when it comes to
God of War because it is definitely one
of the franchises that I've grown up
with and I really enjoy but and until
next time this is Lord addict from Iron
Lords podcast we are on Twitter at iron
Lord's podcast definitely catch us every
Sunday at 1pm and every Wednesday at 5
PM that's my own show every Sunday at
1pm is the iron Lords podcast the main
show and every Wednesday at 5 PM is my
show and I hope you guys enjoy and until
next time this is Lord addict I'm out of
here peace foreign